Générique
- Alexandre Poussart:
Bonjour à tous.
Bienvenue dans "Parlement hebdo".
On revient sur l'actualité de la
semaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder: L'invité
politique est Thomas Portes.
Vous êtes député La France
Insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis.
- Alexandre Poussart: A la une, le
Parlement et la nation sous le
choc après une attaque au couteau
à Annecy qui a visé plusieurs
enfants.
Les députés ont observé une minute
de silence.
C'est fini pour la proposition de
loi du groupe LIOT, qui prévoyait
d'abroger le recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite.
Les députés vont voter en début de
semaine sur une motion de censure
du gouvernement.
L'étau de la commission d'enquête
du Sénat sur le Fonds Marianne se
resserre autour de Marlène
Schiappa.
Les sénateurs s'interrogent sur le
rôle de la ministre dans le
pilotage de ce fonds public.
- Kathia Gilder: D'abord, le
recueillement et les questions
après le drame effroyable
d'Annecy, où de jeunes enfants ont
été attaqués au couteau.
Vous étiez en séance à l'Assemblée
nationale quand vous avez appris
la nouvelle.
Quelle doit être la réponse?
- Thomas Portes: La première
réponse, c'est d'abord de la
compassion à destination des
familles, des parents des enfants
qui ont été victimes de ce drame.
Mathilde Panot a pris la parole à
l'Assemblée pour dire l'émotion
que nous avons.
C'est un drame.
Il y a du recueillement.
Le pays est encore sous le choc et
l'émotion de ce drame.
S'en prendre à des enfants avec un
couteau, c'est très fort.
- Alexandre Poussart: Certains
s'interrogent, à droite, sur le
statut de l'assaillant, qui a
obtenu l'asile en Suède il y a 10
ans.
Il s'est vu refuser le statut de
réfugié en France.
Le ministre de l'Intérieur y voit
une coïncidence troublante.
- Thomas Portes: Il y a une chose
qui doit s'imposer, c'est un délai
de décence.
La première réaction qu'aurait dû
avoir l'ensemble des responsables
politiques, c'est d'avoir des mots
de compassion.
Je regrette que certains se soient
jetés les deux pieds dans de la
récupération politique, notamment
la présidente du groupe
parlementaire Renaissance, Aurore
Bergé, qui est allée tout de suite
dire que ce genre de drames ne
pouvait plus arriver...
On a l'habitude de dire que la
parole est d'argent et que le
silence est d'or.
Certains auraient mieux fait de se
taire.
Il faut attendre que l'enquête
soit faite.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est parfois
difficile de maîtriser ses
émotions quand il arrive quelque
chose comme ça.
- Thomas Portes: Il y a de
l'émotion, de la colère, de la
compréhension, mais nous sommes
des responsables politiques.
Nous avons des responsabilités.
Nous sommes là pour ne pas ajouter
de tumulte dans le débat.
Il ne faut pas souffler sur les
braises qui sont ardentes.
Malheureusement, la droite l'a
fait.
Nous avons vu des militants
néonazis défiler dans les rues
d'Annecy hier soir.
- Kathia Gilder: On va parler des
retraites.
Vous étiez à l'Assemblée nationale
jeudi.
Le texte d'abrogation de la
retraite à 64 ans était à l'ordre
du jour.
- Le règlement, rien que le
règlement.
La Constitution, rien que la
Constitution.
C'est mon rôle et j'aurais aimé
que chacun dans cet hémicycle en
fasse de même.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet huée par la
NUPES.
La présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale a déclaré irrecevables
les amendements pour annuler la
retraite à 64 ans.
L'opposition dénonce un déni de
démocratie.
- Vous oubliez la séparation des
pouvoirs.
- Je ne suis que la misérable
courroie de transmission d'un
passage en force ahurissant.
- Vous n'avez pas de majorité sur
ce texte, ni dans cette Assemblée
ni dans le peuple!
- Vous nous avez empêchés de
voter!
Vous êtes devenu fous!
- Un hémicycle enflammé.
On dénonce un coup de
communication et le vide de la
proposition de loi du groupe LIOT.
- Que cherchez-vous?
Que cherchez-vous, en réalité?
Vous souhaitez uniquement
renverser la table et mettre à mal
nos institutions.
- Le groupe LIOT en est réduit à
retirer son texte, vidé de sa
mesure phare.
- Nous retirons notre projet de
loi, consternés par les attaques
contre notre Parlement.
Vive le Parlement, vive la
République, vive la France.
- Avant d'espérer tourner la page
des retraites, il va falloir
affronter une nouvelle motion de
censure.
- Kathia Gilder: Parlons de cette
motion de censure.
Vous allez la porter pour LFI.
Pourquoi la porter?
Il y a peu de chances qu'elle
aboutisse.
- Thomas Portes: C'est vous qui le
dites.
La dernière fois, il n'y a que
neuf voix qui ont sauvé le
gouvernement.
On n'a pas pu voter en deuxième
lecture.
On va déposer une motion de
censure aujourd'hui, pour qu'elle
soit discutée lundi.
Les Républicains doivent prendre
leurs responsabilités.
Chacun doit prendre ses
responsabilités.
Plusieurs collègues de la majorité
disent qu'ils sont favorables à
l'abrogation de l'âge de départ à
la retraite.
- Alexandre Poussart: Si cette
motion de censure est rejetée,
est-ce que cela ne va pas
conforter le gouvernement
d'Elisabeth Borne?
- Thomas Portes: Cette motion de
censure vise à montrer qui sont
les gens qui ont du courage
politique.
Il y aura des députés Les
Républicains qui auront la
responsabilité de voter cette
motion de censure.
Personne ne veut la retraite à 64
ans.
C'est le fruit de plusieurs mois
de piétinement de la démocratie.
- Kathia Gilder: Pas de vote sur
la retraite à 64 ans, mais la
Constitution a été respectée,
selon le gouvernement.
Pour vous, cela pose un problème
démocratique?
- Thomas Portes: Oui.
Quand la représentation nationale
ne peut pas s'exprimer sur un
texte dont le pays ne veut pas,
dont les gens ne veulent pas, il y
a un problème de démocratie.
Comment voulez-vous que les gens
s'apaisent s'il n'y a pas de
sortie de crise?
La sortie de crise, ça ne peut pas
être: "Circulez, il n'y a rien à
voir."
On dit qu'on veut que les
parlementaires s'expriment.
Dans quel pays est-ce que l'on vit
pour empêcher les parlementaires
de s'exprimer sur un sujet aussi
central que la réforme des
retraites?
- Alexandre Poussart: La
présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale a été très critiquée par
les oppositions.
On lui reproche de s'être opposée
à ce vote sur l'abrogation de la
retraite à 64 ans.
Est-ce qu'elle peut encore
présider cette institution?
- Thomas Portes: Elle a montré
hier qu'elle était la
télégraphiste de l'Elysée.
Elle a empêché le vote.
Elle ne se comporte pas comme une
présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale.
Il y a des incidents dès qu'elle
préside les séances.
Elle envoie des petites piques,
elle reprend les députés de
l'opposition.
Elle disait qu'elle serait là pour
assurer le fonctionnement de
l'Assemblée nationale, mais ce
n'est pas vrai.
Il faut se rappeler que sous la
mandature précédente, elle a été
présidente de la commission des
lois.
C'est elle qui a enterré l'affaire
sur Alexandre Benalla.
C'est elle qui a empêché
l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
commission d'enquête parlementaire
suite aux nouveaux éléments sur
Alexandre Benalla en 2019.
En ce moment, elle empêche une
commission d'enquête que nous
demandons sur le Fonds Marianne.
Elle est au service d'Emmanuel
Macron.
C'est très grave.
La séparation des pouvoirs, c'est
une garantie de nos institutions.
Emmanuel Macron ne peut pas venir
à l'Assemblée, mais il a une
présidente qui exécute sa voix.
- Kathia Gilder: L'exécutif semble
miser sur l'essoufflement du
mouvement.
Il y a eu la 14e journée de
mobilisation, mais il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup de manifestants.
Pour vous, c'est la fin de la
mobilisation?
- Thomas Portes: Je ne crois pas.
Il y avait du monde dans la rue.
Il y a des gens qui sont sortis
pour dire leur opposition.
Il y a eu une mobilisation sociale
inédite depuis 1968.
On a des journées d'action depuis
le 19 janvier dernier.
Les gens ont fait grève pendant
10, 15, 20 jours.
Je connais des gens qui ont fait
deux mois de grève, comme des
éboueurs, qui ont des petits
salaires.
Il y a une fatigue.
L'opinion publique n'a pas changé
d'avis.
Les gens sont toujours opposés à
la réforme.
La colère ne va pas s'arrêter car
le 14 juillet va arriver.
C'est la fin des 100 jours
d'apaisement promis par le
président.
Pour nous, c'est une date qui fait
écho à un événement, la prise de
la Bastille.
- Alexandre Poussart: Si on prend
du recul sur cette séquence de la
réforme des retraites, est-ce que
la stratégie de La France
Insoumise a été la bonne?
Mettre de l'agitation dans
l'hémicycle, exprimer de la
colère, avec des propos et des
images parfois violents, cette
stratégie a été la bonne?
Le Rassemblement National en
récolte les fruits.
- Thomas Portes: Je suis au coeur
des mobilisations.
Quand je rencontre les habitants
de ma circonscription,
ils ne me parlent pas du
Rassemblement National.
Vous avez des leçons pendant des
semaines sur la question de la
violence.
On a traduit la colère populaire
dans l'hémicycle.
Cette loi n'a pas été votée.
La première fois, la loi a été
déposée dans un cadre de PLFSS.
Cela n'a jamais été fait.
Déjà, ils ont utilisé un premier
artifice avec un temps de débat
contraint.
On a mené le combat dans
l'Assemblée.
Aujourd'hui, on ne sait plus
combien de personnes vont être
concernées par cette réforme.
On permet à la mobilisation
sociale de s'organiser.
- Kathia Gilder: Cette semaine,
vous avez adopté la loi de
programmation militaire, 413
milliards d'euros pour transformer
notre modèle des armées.
Il y a eu deux semaines de débats
et un vote solennel.
- Le scrutin est ouvert.
Le scrutin est clos.
Voici le résultat.
548 votants.
Exprimés: 495.
Majorité: 248.
C'est adopté.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous, vous avez
voté contre.
Pourquoi?
- Thomas Portes: Nous étions en
désaccord sur la question de
l'utilisation des objectifs de
cette loi de programmation
militaire.
Il y a des milliards qui vont être
mis sur la table.
La question de la sécurité
nationale de la défense est
stratégique.
Nous avons déposé un projet sur
cette loi.
Il y a la question du maintien
dans l'OTAN.
Il y a la question de la
dissuasion nucléaire.
dépendance vis-à-vis des
sous-traitants et des puissances
étrangères sur la livraison des
porte-avions américains.
Il y a la question de la
transition écologique.
On ne réfléchit pas à
l'après-pétrole.
- Alexandre Poussart: Quand on
voit le contexte géopolitique,
avec Vladimir Poutine qui mène sa
guerre sur le sol européen, est-ce
que ce n'est pas bon pour
l'Europe, la dissuasion nucléaire?
- Thomas Portes: On nous a dit que
c'était un moyen de protéger les
Français.
Mais nous avons proposé un
commissariat à la dissuasion qui
permette de réunir des chercheurs
et des scientifiques pour
réfléchir à la dissuasion de
demain.
Dans 30 ans, la dissuasion
nucléaire pourra être contournée
par de nouveaux éléments.
Il faut réfléchir à l'avenir de la
dissuasion nucléaire.
Il faut réfléchir à des
armements...
On a beaucoup parlé de l'OTAN, qui
était une des armes qui permettait
d'assurer la sécurité des
Françaises et des Français.
La dissuasion permet d'assurer la
sécurité des Français, pas l'OTAN.
L'OTAN aurait dû disparaître au
lendemain de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale.
Il y a eu le retour du
commandement intégré sous le
quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy.
C'est un outil d'influence
américaine au sein de l'Europe,
l'OTAN.
Il faut que le Parlement se
positionne pour savoir si nous
devons rester dans le commandement
intégré de l'OTAN.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va parler
de l'affaire du Fonds Marianne.
La commission d'enquête du Sénat
sur ce sujet avait auditionné
Marlène Schiappa mercredi.
Les sénateurs s'interrogent sur
son rôle réel dans le pilotage de
ce fonds.
On pointe de graves
dysfonctionnements.
- Marlène Schiappa a-t-elle menti
sur son rôle dans l'attribution du
Fonds Marianne?
Si l'Inspection générale de
l'administration des
douanes le dit dans son rapport,
la ministre s'est effacée du
processus, une fois passé le
lancement officiel.
Elle serait intervenue pour
refuser l'attribution d'une
subvention à une association, SOS
Racisme.
- Nous avons une réserve de la
ministre, en raison d'un
historique de relations.
- Cette ingérence sème le doute au
sein de la commission d'enquête
sur l'implication de la ministre
dans cette affaire.
- Qu'un ministre puisse avoir son
mot à dire sur des propositions de
subventions, ce n'est pas le
sujet.
Le sujet, c'est que Marlène
Schiappa a toujours dit qu'elle
n'avait pas participé à ce choix.
Il y a une contradiction entre ce
qu'elle a toujours dit et la
réalité.
- Les membres de la commission
d'enquête espèrent faire la
lumière sur ces contradictions
lors de l'audition de la ministre
la semaine prochaine.
- Les mécanismes de décision, tout
cela n'est pas clair.
Il y a de la porosité entre
l'administration et le politique.
On va recouper les différentes
auditions et les déclarations,
dont je rappelle qu'ils sont faits
sous serment.
- Les sénateurs vont écouter d'une
autre oreille l'audition du
gestionnaire de la subvention.
Accablé par le rapport, il a
démissionné mercredi.
- Alexandre Poussart: C'est une
affaire politique?
- Thomas Portes: Oui.
C'est une stratégie du fusible qui
est utilisée.
On fait sauter le préfet chargé de
la gestion de l'argent récolté.
Il y avait une responsabilité
politique du ministère.
Marlène Schiappa était chargée du
ministère.
On dit que la ministre est
intervenue directement dans le
dossier pour faire en sorte que
SOS Racisme n'ait pas 100.000
euros de subventions parce qu'elle
avait un désaccord politique avec
le président.
- Kathia Gilder: Marlène Schiappa
est en position confortable pour
rester au gouvernement?
- Thomas Portes: Elle doit tirer
les leçons de ce qui s'est passé
et quitter le gouvernement.
Ca fait longtemps qu'elle aurait
dû le quitter.
C'est une énorme histoire de
copinage.
On parle d'un fonds qui a été créé
au lendemain de l'assassinat
horrible de Samuel Paty.
C'était censé diffuser du contenu
pour lutter contre le séparatisme
en ligne.
Finalement, quand on regarde le
rapport, il y a eu une des
associations qui a touché 300.000
euros, et on ne sait pas ce
qu'elle a fait de l'argent.
Une autre association publique a
eu des attaques contre les
candidats à l'élection
présidentielle.
On a financé des gens qui menaient
des campagnes au service du
président de la République.
- Alexandre Poussart: Marlène
Schiappa n'est pas mise en cause
dans le rapport administratif.
Elle n'est pas mise en examen.
Elle a vraiment cette
responsabilité?
- Thomas Portes: L'ancien préfet
dit qu'il fallait plus de temps
pour attribuer l'argent et le
cabinet de la ministre est
intervenu pour dire qu'il fallait
aller plus vite.
On ne peut pas croire qu'il n'y
ait pas une gestion politique du
dossier.
Ce n'est pas une simple question
administrative.
C'est une question politique.
La responsable politique, c'était
Marlène Schiappa.
- Kathia Gilder: Sous quelle forme
pourrait prendre cette initiative
de commission d'enquête à
l'Assemblée?
- Thomas Portes: Les commissions
d'enquête, elles ne sont pas
uniquement ouvertes au droit de
tirage.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous voulez une
commission d'enquête de
l'Assemblée nationale?
- Thomas Portes: Elle se met en
première ligne pour protéger
Emmanuel Macron et le pouvoir,
Yaël Braun-Pivet.
- Alexandre Poussart: Marlène
Schiappa a déjà répondu aux
insoumis.
Elle dit qu'elle n'a aucun lien
avec ces associations.
- Thomas Portes: La commission
d'enquête permettra de le dire.
On ne sait pas ce qui a été fait
avec l'argent.
Ce n'est pas le préfet qui était
chargé du fonds ministériel qui
prenait les décisions.
Je ne crois pas qu'elle n'ait pas
eu de regard sur l'argent de ce
fonds.
Elle faisait le tour de tous les
plateaux télé.
Elle appelait à donner de
l'argent.
Il y a un dossier politique
derrière.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce qu'il y a
nécessité de mettre en place ces
fonds?
C'est utile, pour vous?
- Alexandre Poussart: Ce n'est que
de la communication?
- Thomas Portes: Ce n'est que de
la communication.
En plus, ça a servi à des
associations qui n'ont rien fait
de l'argent.
Là, on est sur une affaire où on
instrumentalise l'assassinat d'un
professeur, Samuel Paty, pour
créer un fonds, récolter de
l'argent, le donner à des
associations et interdire à
d'autres d'y avoir accès.
C'est scandaleux.
De l'argent public a été dilapidé.
La famille de Samuel Paty
elle-même s'est dite très choquée.
- Kathia Gilder: On va regarder
l'agenda de l'Assemblée et du
Sénat.
- Alexandre Poussart: L'agenda du
Sénat sera marqué par les
auditions importantes de la
commission d'enquête sur le Fonds
Marianne mardi à 9h.
Les sénateurs entendront le
dirigeant de l'Union des sociétés
de l'éducation physique et de
préparation militaire, une
association mise en cause dans
cette affaire.
Marlène Schiappa sera ensuite
auditionnée.
Sonia Backes répondra également
aux questions des sénateurs.
- Kathia Gilder: A l'Assemblée
nationale, la motion de censure
est attendue en début de semaine,
à partir de lundi.
Les députés examineront ainsi une
proposition de loi pour répartir
l'offre de santé sur le territoire
et lutter contre les déserts
médicaux.
- Alexandre Poussart: C'est la fin
de cette émission.
Merci à tous.
- Kathia Gilder:
A la semaine prochaine.